[Música]
la pandemia de coronavirus nos ha
cambiado en muchos aspectos y sin duda
ha modificado nuestra forma de vida de
trabajar de relacionarnos también de
comportarnos la automatización y
digitalización ya son parte esencial del
mundo laboral y en los próximos años
esto se va a acentuar si bien muchos de
los empleos tal como se conocen hoy en
día van a desaparecer también van a
surgir otras alternativas según los
expertos los trabajos que mejor van a
resistir a estos avances tecnológicos
serán aquellos a centrados en el
conocimiento la subjetividad y el valor
humano en la más reciente conferencia
internacional del trabajo de la oit los
gobiernos y los trabajadores y
empleadores hicieron un llamado a la
acción centrada en las personas con
estrategias inclusivas sostenibles y
también resilientes para ello entonces
quiero darle la bienvenida a quien va a
ser nuestro primer invitado del día el
es de vinicius piñeiro director regional
de la organización internacional del
trabajo para américa latina y también el
caribe gracias de inicios por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
pregunto cómo ha cambiado entonces la
vida laboral después y durante esta
pandemia que todavía no se ha acabado
en primer lugar bueno gracias por
invitarnos la verdad es que la pandemia
no nos agobia en especial américa en el
caribe de manera muy brutal pudimos la
gestión más copiada del mundo y eso se
da en especial por cuenta de los altos
niveles de informalidad de la ausencia
de sistemas de presión social que sean
efectivos y esos ingresos con
probabilidades sociales han amplificado
el efecto la pandemia en nuestra región
y lo que pasó es que por supuesto el
impacto si sería un débil de nivel es
una parte de la economía la economía que
era más posible del auto más central
digitalizan a ese lapso de es ese cambio
de manera muy brusca no y ahora en el
futuro de trabajo llegó sin avisar para
muchos que ya está entre trabajo que
vivieron sus procesos de automoción
sus tareas
acelerando y eso ha abierto una cantidad
de oportunidades que desafortunadamente
la gestión no está preparada para para
hacer frente no
russo hoy hay muchas brechas de la
informática a la gente es por ejemplo
ingenieros de cloud personas que
trabajan con sistemas
el alumno que en este trabajo de cómbita
hoy tenemos un tercio de cuatro son esos
en estos procesos y por otro lado la
pandemia también ha afectado a gentes
que en la informalidad y siguen haciendo
sus trabajos en sistemas de baja
productividad entonces este espiritual
la pandemia todavía tenemos que
superarlo pero la verdad es que por un
lado ha creado oportunidades aquí
desafortunamente no estamos listos para
el día porque lo tenemos en los sistemas
educacionales de preparación para esta
fuerza de magma para ser mano de obra es
esté ya funcionando he programado ha
reproducido formas históricas de
trabajar por su trabajo infantil que han
acentuado la verdad es que nos catapultó
a su futuro por un lado pero también
significó
retroceso no con respecto a muchos otros
temas de inicios cuáles son esos
trabajos que se podrían ver
especialmente más afectados con todo
este avance a la digitalización como ya
lo estábamos hablando que ustedes cuando
han estudiado pues este comportamiento
hacia dónde vamos además que cuáles son
los trabajos que más se ven afectados
si sus trabajos que quienes quieren una
son tareas repetitivas que pueden ser
que puede ser fácilmente en casa dos
formas como por ejemplo y eso lo que son
sus posiciones y te las dan porque uno
seguido por la mañana o sea
el trabajo es una secuencia de tareas y
vigilancia que
un abogado entonces es una persona que
trabaja nuestros servicios
qué tipos de tareas dentro de esa
profesión que puede ser automatizados
entonces arias es un cálculo que uno
tiene que hacer cuanto más
efectivo son las tareas mayor la
probabilidad de automación entonces lo
que pasa muchos casos que algunas y
algunas profesiones el 50% las tareas
pueden ser dos necesidades entonces este
profesional la verdad tiene que
pasar un proceso de calificación para
poder aumentar su oportunidad teniendo
en cuenta que tengo una máquina va a ser
gran parte del trabajo he visto que no
hacía entonces tareas más repetitivas
nadie tiene un contenido incluso del
esfuerzo más más intenso son
más fácil es decir automatizados también
esto tiene que ver con la tecnología
usted estaba diciendo que hay una brecha
muy grande sobre toda nuestra región en
américa latina y el caribe de la
tecnología para llegar a esa
automatización de algunas tareas la
mujer puede ser logística eventualmente
transportistas que pudieran ser
reemplazados por robots o por una
máquina
cómo estamos nosotros qué tan grande es
la brecha en los países más
desarrollados y américa latina en cuanto
a la tecnología para llegar a esta
automatización laboral
es una persona ordinaria y no es
solamente la brecha de acceso
tecnológico pero también la
infraestructura
imagínense ustedes por ejemplo el debate
acerca de los autos son
automatizados son diálogos hemos estado
por sistemas de robots una cosa es que
lo hagan estas carreteras que son súper
buenas que
no tienen ningún problema estructural
otra cosa es que estos autos estén ahí
navegando entre los huecos de las
carreteras de todas las posibilidades y
hay de accidente de tránsito no entonces
antes de implementar esos procesos es
fundamental por ejemplo que haya
carreteras que haya buenos caminos no de
debilidad porque
todavía en muchos casos no estamos
listos no para para ingresar el proceso
de automación total mientras que no hay
estructura y la viene resultó también
tecnológica nada de implementar son los
sistemas de 5 que nadie quiere
también parte de la de los sistemas
basados en tener las cosas que quieres
sino que tampoco está disponible de
manera muy amplia en la gente entonces
antes de pensar un proceso de automación
como lo están ya implementaron los
países de datos europeos es fundamental
una inversión en infraestructura pues
son la inclusión del antes progresos de
apertura física y también en cerrar las
dejas veces digitales